isn't it ironic that brett farr was
taking all those shots from 300-pound
linemen and a shot of his penis is the
one that's finally gonna force him to
retire yeah good to be in the salvation
we had fun of the veneration right like
the no others don't get that the south
is in more races because we [ __ ] around
we have fun like my four roommates in
college for black dudes my best friend's
on my campus but we would have fun with
that [ __ ] like they would pull up to a
gas station with me and they'd say some
[ __ ] like se/4 se/4 know strung can I
ask you open against the discount is dad
okay all right okay or you can just rock
them
yeah walk back and forth I I'm escorting
this one let me tell you this want you
put on that old towel till your cousins
and I right to give up that oil this is
a bore everybody all right okay well why
are you so afraid of jail when we both
know that's the only place you'll ever
find your real father a rod you know you
want a World Series now right you're
allowed to date hot girls in how much
air Johnson sucks I google them and then
ten google images I saw eight different
people not never been searched in the
airport with you're not [ __ ]
embarrassing that is a promise to never
get started the airport I'm so excluded
from my community on issue did you know
there's like what to minority to get
discriminate against the same way it's
like a moment of bonding commit right I
can connect over that [ __ ] I'm left the
[ __ ] out of that conversation every time
me and Ron friends are we talking 10 be
like do I got search for 20 minutes on
my last airplane flight and I said oh
boo I got certain to 35 minutes on my
last airplanes like you'll see like a
connection in their eyes
we'll try to draw me and they'll be like
what about you oh gosh they told me
Mexicans don't blow plans Thanks they
told me they asked me to fix the plane I
need to go get boards for them at some
point they should change the name of
that show too dancing with hope